we begin this half hour with a new
challenge to affirmative action policies
on college campuses this week the
supreme court agreed to hear a pair of
cases brought against harvard and the
university of north carolina the
lawsuits allege the school's admissions
policies discriminate against
asian-american applicants if the suits
are successful colleges and universities
may no longer be able to use race as a
factor in the admissions process now
natalie brand reports on the arguments
that could be heard by the court in the
fall
what do we do
[Applause]
it's a years-long legal battle that's
divided some students at one of the
nation's most prestigious universities
race cannot be removed effectively from
an application just because it is so
central to so many people's identity
we're not against that someone should
not be providing their racial
information but how is that going to be
used is a big question the lawsuit that
started in 2014 accusing harvard of
discriminating against asian american
applicants is now receiving new
attention from the u.s supreme court
harvard has denied the claims and lower
courts have ruled in the school's favor
but the high court this week agreed to
hear the challenge to race conscious
admissions policies at harvard and also
the university of north carolina this
case could have a dramatic effect ken
marcus chairman of the brandeis center
has written a friend of the court brief
in support of the group challenging
affirmative action students for fair
admissions they believe the new
conservative majority supreme court will
revisit decades of precedent are
universities really using race only as
one factor among many or are they
tipping the scales as they want to based
on their subjective considerations
harvard's president in a statement says
considering race as one factor among
many in admissions decisions produces a
more diverse student body which
strengthens the learning environment for
all
needy shah of asian americans advancing
justice aajc agrees
because we know for
better for worse than there is
discrimination in america today and
there are disparities in education her
group is among those fighting to keep
affirmative action in place we will
continue to fight for
diverse
inclusive learning environments that
benefit all students including asian
american students while shaw is hopeful
past precedent is on their side i think
the
current supreme court
majority is
radically uninterested in
paying attention to precedent
george washington university law
professor paul schiff berman says if the
court overturns the past precedent he
believes it will hurt the educational
experience for everyone i think that the
educational mission the imperative to
make sure that universities
have diverse perspectives
will continue to be an imperative
how universities will do that
i don't know and certainly the u.s
supreme court is likely to make it much
much more difficult the supreme court is
expected to hear the high stakes case
next term a decision isn't expected
until 2023
for cbs saturday morning natalie brandt
washington
we've seen this before you know the u.s
military has stepped up in amicus briefs
uh so has sof corporations to say you
know this is really important in places
not only of work but certainly in the
educational process but a different
court now a different perspective yeah
different lens and always evolving court